moderate senators agreeing with
president biden on an infrastructure
package and then you've got progressives
like senator bernie sanders saying we
want a whole lot more maybe as much
as six trillion dollars with that let's
bring in our panel molly hemingway
senior editor at the federalist
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman and ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital
and jason reilly wall street journal
columnist and senior fellow at the
manhattan institute he is also the
author of a new book maverick a
biography of thomas soule
panel welcome
great to be here so congressman harold
ford jr
um what do we have going on on the
democratic side of things are they
trying to
keep the progressives in check while
they also
appease the moderates what's going on
well first thanks for having me and
congrats to jason on the new book i look
forward to reading it
as i listen to the parties that be from
mitch mcconnell center mcconnell
to even senator sanders it reminded me
of two things that
this by should say this effort to get a
bipartisan achievement around
infrastructure is really a test for
whether or not bipartisanship
remains a part of the relevant
vernacular current vernacular and
politics i think it does and hope it
does
it also signals to leaders that we don't
have the luxury
leaders in washington they don't have
the luxury in a deeply deeply divided
country in a country where people have
lost trust and confidence in government
to just always say no i think when you
find
conservatives and liberals those on the
opposite sides in each party finding
issue or having difference with a
compromise or some sort of bipartisan
compromise
i think that's when americans are going
to dig down and listen and hope that the
congress can move forward democrats are
not going to be happy with all of this
republicans clearly are not
but the country needs to redo and
strengthen our infrastructure and this
gives us a huge down payment
to do that over the next several years i
asked senate republican leader mitch
mcconnell about infrastructure let's
take a listen
you can best be described as a tale of
two press conferences after the first
one
the president walks out with a
bipartisan group and blesses an
infrastructure bill that
many of my members are quite optimistic
about
and then after all of those people
depart the white house the president
goes out
for the second press conference and says
unless you pass my tax bill i won't sign
the infrastructure bill we've gone from
optimism to pessimism as a result of the
president's
second press conference
molly how do you see it well it was a
very interesting day in washington it
starts out with this
very big announcement that there had
been a bipartisan agreement
on infrastructure it is worth noting
that infrastructure should be one of the
easiest things to get bipartisan
agreement on
and the fact that it's taken this long
is is not a great sign
but here you had these people really
operating in seemingly good faith
to get together on a bipartisan bill
then nancy pelosi blows it up by saying
she won't allow it to go she won't allow
it to happen
unless there's this massive spending
package that's been a non-starter
for a lot of republicans or even just
people remotely concerned about
fiscal responsibility which they're few
and far between in this town
but then president biden gives this
press conference where he says
he agrees with nancy pelosi it was
utterly bizarre
and it the press conference in general
was weird he kept on whispering
weird things like when he blamed
businesses for the problem they're
having with
being able to hire people he said that
they need to compete with the fact that
the government is taking their money to
pay people not to work and that if they
want people to work they should just pay
them more
it was very it was very odd and i think
it was disconcerting for a lot of people
to say what is going on here jason did
they get something done or does this all
blow up in the hot summer
i kind of hope it blows up uh mike
frankly i
i think that mitch mcconnell is wise to
be skeptical of this
you know barry goldwater urged
republicans to offer a choice
not simply an echo and i think the
senators pushing for this
are really offering an echo they they
don't care about how much is being spent
they don't care whether we can really
afford to pay for it they just want to
make sure that the money is spent on
their priorities as well as
democratic priorities and i think the
voters deserve better than that this is
part of a much larger biden agenda
to take us back to world war two level
spending
mike i mean the last time i checked we
were not at war let alone a war on the
scale of what was going on 80 years ago
uh this is what this bill is really
about and i don't think that
that the american public would have
split the the senate 50 50 if this is
what they wanted
okay to vice president harris going to
the border tomorrow to el paso let's
play this clip and i'll have you all
respond
was it important for the white house to
have her
seen at the border before former
president trump has a trip there
next week we made an assessment within
our government about when it was an
appropriate time for her to go to the
border she's going where she's not
really going to be seeing
active crossings i don't think they want
them crossing behind her in a camera
shot
imagine you had a problem break out in
washington dc and she wanted to get to
the hot spot and she landed in boston
she wouldn't be in the right spot if
she's going to do it do it right and
don't laugh it off it's a serious
situation people are dying
harold your thoughts
so a couple things i think our foreign
policy we we have to begin to look at
the border as a national security
challenge as part of a broader foreign
policy challenge
now when you approach a big reform deal
whether it's infrastructure immigration
on either side of the aisle you've got
to get two things right number one is
substance
and number two the politics i think vice
president harris has gotten some of the
substance if not a lot of it right with
the way she's looked at the root causes
but the politics she has not gotten
right hopefully this acts as an
accelerant
her traveling to the border and visiting
there because it is a crisis at the
border
but i might add in just a moment of
levity here and and perhaps uh lightness
here
if visiting the border would solve our
border challenge and border immigration
challenge then we would have solved this
problem a long long time ago president
trump visited
even cruz and graham and all the
senators who do all this big complaining
they've all gone down and we've not
solved anything
this has to be viewed as a part of a
long-term
a long-term solution or certainly a big
solution to a long-term problem
remember the last time we had
immigration reform in this country was
35 years ago and that president
was ronald reagan a lot has changed a
lot has gotten worse and we're going to
need a big package to get it right so
the vice president is going
to el paso she's not going to the rio
grande valley or to the holding facility
in donna texas
molly your thoughts that's exactly right
it's
it is good to go to the border it's good
that she was finally pressured into
going to the border
because president trump is visiting but
it's not sufficient to go down there
have a laugh and keep things going the
same way that they are it'd be better if
she visited fort bliss
one of these contractor facilities where
2 000 teenagers are being held
where there are lice outbreaks and strep
and flu and covid19 and the food is
substandard
where she actually saw the pain caused
by the policies of the biden
administration
and what's happening is because of the
biden administration a series of
executive orders
a decision not to turn anyone away and
even now welcoming people
not just unaccompanied minors but single
people families
and making a visit to a place where
there's not much of a problem isn't
going to do anything
you need to actually have her understand
the problem the pain
and every all of the all of the problems
caused by having an open porous border
or else it's not worth a trip at all
jason do you see a policy change coming
soon
i'm not so sure i think this is more
about optics i think i
i see this as part of what was going on
earlier this week with the
administration sudden discovery that we
have a
violent crime problem in many of our big
cities uh this president came in and
thought he would just do the opposite of
everything donald trump was doing so
if trump had played up violent crime
he'd play it down if trump played up a
border problem
he would play it down but these are real
problems um
and now he's suddenly realizing that and
that he has to do something about them
so i think they're they're playing catch
up here
all right to the voting rights bill i
asked senator mcconnell about that let's
take a listen
if the president wants to keep on
talking about it we'd like to keep on
talking about it too
because there's no voter suppression
going on in any state in america
and the bill they were trying to pass
would have taxpayer dollars spent on
political campaigns
would turn the federal election
commission from a judge into a
prosecutor in other words make it un
unbalanced and prevent photo id at the
polls something supported by 80 percent
of americans so
if the president wants to keep on
talking about uh this bill
so do we all right we got less than a
minute left let's see if we can go
around the horn real fast harold your
thoughts
look we had the biggest turnout we had
the least problems
ever in a federal election why we would
make any changes these states are making
changes and the federal government's
trying to correct
or trying to prevent those changes from
hurting voter turnout it's unfortunate
and hopefully they figure this thing out
molly
it was not true that this was this was
an election without problems and in fact
as people have moved to to mail in
balloting people need to have
confidence that it's not just that
people are free to vote but that also
it's difficult
to cheat and so this is a very salient
issue and republicans are finding that
despite all of the propaganda press in
favor of democrats plan
it's not very popular with the people
and so they're happy to keep talking
about it because
they know that the voters really do
appreciate basic election integrity
measures
such as voter id jason file thought from
you
there is no voting rights problem in
this country there was record turnout
among asians and hispanics in 2020
among blacks it was the third highest
turnout after 2008 and 2012 and of
course barack
obama was on the ballot this is not
about voting rights this is a power grab
from the federal government
all right we need to leave it there